I just recovered from a terrible
hardship I left my feet on an airplane
super dumb don't wait for me though
after much searching I bought another
Vita just before a healthy heaping of
fantastic games are set to hit the
digital store here's a sneak peek at six
games that I've just played and that you
need to know about you may still be
scarred by the troubling launch of the
Vita games try to use all the systems
functionality and we get up with solace
gimmicks like little deviants bad times
but there is a silver lining to us
failed experiments behold more sake baby
an endearing puzzler that couldn't exist
without the Vita's many control inputs
guide baby by holding her hand through
the hellish landscape and manipulate
wind rain demonic screamers and other
oddities to guide her to the promised
land who would envision the likes of
more sake baby and tear away and we are
struggling with Sumi Oni demon arts
nothing is quite as humbling as a
devious puzzler your suave and confident
strutting through brainy barriers
without any hiccups to your giddyup and
then your stumps I love that feeling and
when I finally overcome that challenge
that's one of my favorite parts of
gaming metric 0 is all about that
empowerment the setup is so strange it
sounds like a joke you must master
infographics but you'll stop laughing
soon enough your movement controls the
environment and the rules are never
explained so you've got to figure out a
solution using your own grey matter good
luck you've got six hours to live in
you're hallucinating like a madman
intrigued one way trip is as bizarre as
a talking rooster and twice as a game so
where do your priorities lie are you
concerned with finding a cure so your
arms don't turn into dolphins building
friendships with a strange populace or
questioning how wish very nice princess
could have such a keen fashion sense
it's a narrative trip that branch is
wildly based on your decisions I
honestly have no clue what to expect
from the final release what I've played
is almost aggressively weird though at
least caught my attention
what is the legacy of a road that's for
you to decide my legacy is one of
flatulence and abnormal sighs whatever
that means gigantism or shrink assa T
I'm not telling do you remember spelunky
dying repeatedly in the caves cursing
those unnerving bats it was hard and
there's nothing you could do but
practice rogue legacy is exactly the
same but well the opposite here you die
you fail you get embarrassed and then
you grow you pass your skills on your
kin so when you come up short your air
can thrive it's an excellent concept
that's more accessible to those who fear
pain yet still full of the devious traps
you'd expect from a dirty road there was
a Disney documentary back in 1958 that
popularized a lie many still believe in
white wilderness untold numbers of
lemmings walk to their own death note
lemmings are not actually suicidal but
it spawned a great game so where's the
harm now we're seeing that death wish
infect other animals in super exploding
zoo you round up animals to win a war
against egg-sucking monsters and you do
that by blowing them to pieces weird you
betcha and I was digging the puzzle
solving as I got deeper into the demo
certainly want to watch just don't buy
the propaganda we all know thats flunky
is the king of the rogue lights heck
I've mentioned it twice in this video
and it's been out for ages but number
two on that form of the list The Binding
of Isaac this is one evil game have you
ever wanted to explore the uterus of
hell while vanquishing monsters with
your tears it's like a biography of some
warped person's life there's an all-new
art style and soundtrack from the pc
release that's just as good as the
previous stuff which is damn good the
downside there's slow down at least in
the build i played i'm crossing my
fingers it's cleaned up before release
because i really want to wear Mama's
underwear while i commute to work the
next time someone says there are any
games on the Vita just point them to
this video or you know the hundreds of
games already on the system either way